d
chess.com/events cour tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec qui se déroule
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contterendus
quotidien les bios des joueurs les
règles des partartage et plus encore
vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronosticant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
les amis ça va ça va bientôt bientôt
commencer j'attendais que les joueurs
arrivent parce que j'aime pas trop
rester là devant et vous dire on attend
que ça commence nanani nanana donc là ça
va ça va ça va commencer faut que je
récupère les chiquers qui s'est pas
affiché automatiquement la pendule on
voit qu'il y a une Espagnole et on va
tout de suite être là dans le dans le
vif du sujet j'avais tout mis en place
he bien évidemment pendant que vous avez
la pause
nepomiaashifouja les caméras sont sont
allumé par contre c'est c'est Yan qui a
les blancs dans la première partie
finalement et voili voilou on est on est
au top on a Ali Reza firouja donc avec
les Noirs contre cet Espagnol du du Yan
il y a 0-0 comme vous le voyez c'est la
demi-finale des perdant le premier un
point et demi se qualifie et jouera
contre la zavi qui toujours avec le
maillot du FC
Barcelone un peu le Lionel Messi du
tournoi qui a l'air d'être heureux alia
aussi ils sont tous les deux contents de
se jouer ils sert peut-être moins
contents
dans la finale contre la
zavic le gagnant ici la VI pour
affronter
Magnus et il faudra battre Magnus deux
fois et donc là Yan qui envoie un
bquatro alors est-ce que c'est théorique
ce bquatro tiens est-ce qu'on se pose la
question c'est théorique il y a une
partie dans la petite
base une partie dans la petite B ce
batro ça donne envie de le manger ce
pion et ben oui c'est pris alors quelle
est l'idée de y c'est de faire C3
peut-être d'accélérer de jouer B4 ah sur
fou A5 déjà peut-être fou
A3 mais oui n supporter du
Barça belle équipe après le FC
Barcelone ça pas l'air idiot là ce qu'il
est en train de faire y j'ai bien aimé
le B4 je l'ai trouvé
appréciable
raison en
réflexion raison en réflexion je vais
juste gérer une porte parce qu'il a ma
petite fille qui pleure sinon ça va te
déranger hop ça c'est
gérer c'est un écran surou alors je
pense que c'est l'écran de l'ordinateur
de contrôle sur lequel est branché la
caméra
arrière
le chouchou
à le chouou éliminé hein je sa été
éliminé là lirea qui réfléchit ouais bah
je pense que ça va mal se passer ça va
mal se passer parce
que en vérité sur fou C5 D4 fou B6
là il y a déjà qui prend E5 donc c'est
complètement débile ce que je dis et sur
pion pr il y a E5 donc ça c'est déjà
terminé donc fou a 5 est forcé il va y
avoir fou A3 il y aura dame6 il va y
avoir dame à4 fou B6 cavalier ouais ça a
l'air s'il connaî pas en fait ça a l'air
dur à jouer bon il a fait F a 5 il a
trouvé le seul coup c'est déjà pas
mal
mais ça a l'air compliqué à jouer pour
les Noirs il va avoir du mal à roquer je
suis étonné que F à 5 la y
dubitatif il doit
connaître c'est une petite idée qu'il
avait F à 3 ça c'était
sûr la dame elle doit aller en E6 ça
c'est sûr aussi
ça c'est
obligatoire pas le choix du
tout parce qu'il faut défendre le pion
E5 donc on peut pas on peut pas faire
autrement on peut absolument pas faire
autrement
il réfléchit mais je sais pas à
quoi il réfléchit peut-être à C5 mais C5
il va y avoir juste dame à 4 c'est une
pièce
directe et s'il va sur n'importe quel
autre casque a S
perd5 c'est mauvais signe de ouf là le
début de partie
ouais ça a l'air ça a l'air foutu de
enfin F ça a l'air d'aller mais ça a
l'air d'aller mais s'il connait pas ça a
l'air foutu de ouf il fait dame 6 mais
juste il passe tellement de temps sur
ses
coups piégé enfin piégé dans l'ouverture
ais il s'est pris quelque chose qu'il
connaissait
pas
dame 6 bien joué en tout
cas dame à 4 Bonz il va faire fou
B6 je sais pas pouri il réfléchis autant
en fait ça
me ça me
fracasse c'est la game de chauve dans le
chat et ouais la game de chauffe mais
attention parce qu'il y a que deux
parties donc peut-être que quand tu
seras chaud le match sera déjà
terminé mais là les les timings me font
extrêmement peur
comme s'il était pas dans son assiette
je pense qu'il déteste la position après
fou B6 le fait de pas pouvoir Roer mais
ok tu fais fou D7
et et tu
verras tout façon F il a l'air obligé
non leur est-ce qu'il donne un autre
coup B6 B6 B6 non B6 c'est
trollé il fait
B6
F B6 qui des de C C4 devait le
gêneran qui regarde ce coup avec
dégoût c'est vrai que le coup est
la le coup est vraiment
lait ça on peut pas lui enlever à ce
coup c'est un
coul c'est youou l c'est un coucou
lé est-ce que nian est fan de de World
of Warcraft c'est possible je crois que
c'est vraiment un gamer dans dans l'âme
ce Yan il fait qu' prend 5 sur dame
prend5 il y avait dame prend
C6 il va vouloir jouer avec avec grand
rock finalement qui pas le meilleur coup
et c'est possible que que que ce soit
juste super bien joué de la
part de notre
ami nepom
miashi en tout cas bravo à
lui de notre ami par notre ami Ali
Reza j'en sais rien écoutez on va voir
comment ça se déroule début de par é un
peu étonnant mais cavalier C4 Ilir faire
grand
rock mais b6était moche et donc du coup
le coup cé D4 et comme ça sur fou B7 on
faisait
D5 qui était nettement plus fort en fait
la dame pvait pas rester au contrôle
c'était cavalier de coupsexclamation que
c'est pas le meilleur coup et fou
B7 grand
ro
il se trouve que cavalier prend A5 B
prend A5 dame prend a 5 tour prend D3 le
roi va être safe parce qu'on défend les
cases blanche
ok mais c'est une partie intéressante
finalement c'est marrant parce qu'on
retrouve des parties vraiment humaines
entre guillemets là quand on a de
joueurs de haut niveau et ça redevient
intéressant je peux vous dire qu'il y a
eu des parties qui étaient vraiment très
difficiles à à analyser ce que j'ai fait
sur les chaînes Youtube c'est vraiment
des parties étranges à chaque fois et
ouais il y a quelques quelques trucs des
fois un petit peu marrants et là on
retrouve des parties plus normales avec
des petites erreurs mais tout est très
humain et tout est très
intéressant mais oui là c'est
intéressant de voir qu'en fait prendre 7
ouais le fou B7 est vraiment très
solide donc il joue dame C2 c'est très
bien joué tient le pion des TR
Yan avec l'idée qu'il est euh de de
jouer sur la structure noir complètement
délabré et donc là il y a qu'un seul
coup pour lutter pour l'égalité c'est
Dame D7 avec l'idée sur D4 de jouer C5
et de vraiment s'ouvrir la diagonale du
foot casse blanche en réalité le le
problème un petit peu de de la position
c'est que le fou B7 ne brille pas à
cause du petit Andi muré là qui qui est
venu euh au milieu du du cour nous nous
renvoyer la balle et donc dame D7 c'est
l'idée de venir forcer la poussée du
pion parce que sur tour D1 il y a
cavalier prend E4 et sur D4 il veut
jouer C5 et là le fou qui respire euh et
sur F3 c'est prend des4 donc on a le
temps quand même de de faire quelque
chose je pense que dame D7 va être joué
le coup assez logique l'autre coup ce
serait FO à 6 peut-être mais les les
Noirs les Blancs peuvent placer un
deuxième Andy et donc là il commence à
renvoyer toutes les balles he quand ils
jouent en double les les Andy contre
contre des fous dans la diagonale coup
droit revers ils sont ils sont très
puissants donc c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est vraiment une jolie
partie de
nouveau reste plus que 3 minutes 40 à à
alirea
Dame des 7 c'est pas un coup facile
honnêtement tu peux vouloir jouer tour
H8 mais en fait l'ordi il te il te met
des murs en fait il veut jouer avec F3
C4 et vraiment tenir toutes les cases
c'est hyper intéressant il fait F 6
ouais mais je peux pas dire que c'est
une
erreur c'est vraiment pas facile de
comprendre et là le problème c'est tous
les ouais et et dame D7 maintenant tour
d un cavalier prend4 leur dit fait juste
cavalier C3 et il empacte les Noirs en
fait ouais c'est hyper intéressant là la
partie est hyper
intéressante très très jolie partie là
très très jolie partie cavalier4 je
juste montrer cavalier C3 qui prend C3
dame prend C3 et admettons dame F5 pour
défendre et le problème c'est que ce fou
ne voit plus le jour de la partie on
aura pas le temps de faire fou B7 C5 ça
va être trop long et donc les les blancs
vont pouvoir faire parler leur fou on
s'y joue bien et peut-être même le
redécaler vers G3 W c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique là ce qu' peut faire y
donc pr 4 C3 prise prise dam F5 jouer ça
c'est les coups logiques F5 je même pas
c'était le premier coup de l'ordi mais
c'est vraiment le coup qu'on a envie de
jouer et là les blancs peuvent prendre
l'avantage en venant quelque part jouer
le contournement avec le fou il fait
tourb1 ouais là les noirs sont vraiment
très mal t B1 ça beau être une erreur
c'est le coup logique et dame B3 on va
réussir à avoir roi D7 et peut-être
après F6 roi E6 roi F7 ro G8 wou c'est
téléphone ass mais si on a le temps on a
le
temps si on a le temps on a le
temps très jolie partie mesames et
messieur
messieurs Yan qui est proche d'un
avantage très important
ici alle il boit un petit coup le Yan il
doit avoir un peu le se he parce qu'il
est il est vraiment proche vraiment très
très proche d'être
gagnant il est très très proche mais les
Noirs tiennent la colonne
B et vont tenir même la case B8 donc il
va juste vouloir se barrer très très
gentiment en D7 et après peut-être même
Bam
Bam repartir de l'autre côté c'est pas
obligatoire de repartir mais il aura le
il aura peut-être
l'option et la dame F5 qui tient le pion
qui tape
D3 vous savez quoi cette partie elle
peut même tourner en faveur de
d'aliireza si Yan en veut
trop il a la réussite de son côté Yan
qui peut un peu se taper la tête contre
un mur
là il peut complètement se taper la tête
contre un mur ici
Yan c'est
possible il a l'air de il a un beau
tatouage au
bras il est tatoué Yan il est
tatoué
ah ils là il est vraiment dans le cas de
figure où tu sais que la position peut
être très proche de
gagnant tu le
sais mais tu as pas de
gain et c'est pour ça qu' tque autant
alors nous on le sait hein parce que on
a la la petite tur qui aide et tu te
rends compte que tu peux même te
retrouver moins bien donc il joue un tel
coup que fou c'est1 il comprend que son
fou doit se déplacer et là il a fait la
mou il a fait la mou ah il sait que
c'est il a il a moins que ce qu'il
devait avoir donc là il veut tour de fou
3 pour venir enfermer la
tour c'est bien joué mais vous voyez
qu'il a le se ça se voit de par son
langage
corporel Yan c'est quelqu'un qui cache
pas ses
émotions
alors heureusement pour lui hein sur
tour prend tour prend dame prend dame
prend tour 1 il y a dame F1 al
heureusement évidemment c'était
vu et on
peut est-ce que fou prend C4 peut
marcher dame prend C4 dame prend D3 dame
prend D3
tour t prend des TR pardon et là il va
pas prendre il va juste bouger le fou
pardon je vous montrer cette petite
variante que je trouvais intéressante
il a joué dame 5
ici mauvais coup d'après l'ordi mais ça
va simplement
égaliser il va faire
C5 il est dégoûté il il sait qu'il était
mieux il sait qu'il était mieux et là il
va juste avoir
C5 et heureusement qu' a pas un pion
B6 sinon les Noirs serai carrément
gagnant
mais là il y a un pion de plus pour les
Noirs mais la structure est
délabrée il va ramener la tour en B6
quand
même sur fou F4 il veut tour B6
ouais sur F4 il veut tour B6 et sur tour
Pr B il la tour un mat
ingénieux
ingénieux peut-être tu vas faire G5 F6
H6 après
ouais je ferai G5 F6 H6 ou F5 H6 F5 G5
H6
F5 je pense G5 est vraiment le SC
logique ici
parce que ça vient prendre des cases
noires on veut faire des murs contre le
fou t B6 c'est aussi logique à vrai
dire tour B3 fou B7 ouais c'est
complètement logique aussi il passe la
tour et il met le fou en B7 est-ce qu'il
peut même la gagner
celleela la tour en B3 est bien et mal
placer à la
fois parce que maintenant quand ça
décale en G6 s fait tour B2 il y aura
fou C6 tour B8 tu aura roi D7 et on peut
complètement contourner la défense
adverse sur tour à 3 est-ce que on joue
tour A6 A4 fou C6 peut-être un plan
comme
ça je pense qu'il va jouer tour A6 il y
a pas de raison de donner un pion alors
il fait tour G6 il provoque G3 il va
faire H5 alors
maintenant il va juste rencontrer
H4
il peut tenter fou F3 t reprends à 5
tour B6 tour B5 tour prend pion prend ah
le FO F3 est tellement bien quand même
ça crée des réseaux de ma il doit
calculer
ça il y a aussi tour prend3 pion prend3
t prend G3 qui peut être intéressant roi
F2 t prend H3 mais bon t prend A5
H5 ouis ça peut être intéressant il fait
tour B6 alors il menace tour B1 et tour
h un
mat provoque plus ou moins tour
D1 peut-être maintenant tour à 6 il
aurait dû faire tour à 6 d'abord quand
même fait tour
H5
il essaie de faire quelque chose mais il
veut peut-être H4 H6 tour 5 G5 t prend
C5 il crée des menaces en tout
cas bien joué ça de la part de
Yan parce que là sur tour6 G4
il fait F5 mais alors attention là c'est
hyper risqué ce que fait il
ve il veut G5 et T pr H3 tour H6
mat sur sur sur C5 H3 et sur tour5 Av
G5 il prend des gros risques quand même
parce que maintenant il y a un contre de
l'autre côté
il a joué hyper risqué là trop
risqué du coup il fait tour à sur F pr
C5 il a G5 je sais pas si c'est trop
risqué ou
pas tour B1 il veut tour B5 maintenant
et H6 tour
B5 sur G5 aura t pr F5 et ça
clou
mais il a peut-être F4 il fait GH ça g
ça cloué si on faisait F4 et GH dans les
deux sens ok il va y avoir foupran je
suppose
ah il fait pion prend surtour prend il
veut G3 puis on prend puis on prend
puion prend prise et prise
H5 ah très très jolie
partie reste avec un pion de plus quand
même alira mais il a une structure
pourrie donc je pense que ça
s'équilibre ah les deux joueurs qui
s'envoient là dans cette
game très très partie très agréable
entre les
deux d'accord il va faire fou E2 C5 C6
fou F5 fou d ah il a pas le temps de
faire C6 il va faire fou C4 C5 et il va
mettre le fou en D5 si le le fou atterr
en D5 il sera mieux donc tour à4 il veut
éviter ça il va mettre le pion H5
maintenant non il chasse la tour il fait
un coup d'échec il va jouer à 4 au
prochain il joue hyper bien ala là cette
partie sur D5 qui va faire A6 je
suppose il peut aussi donner le pion et
commencer à pousser non il fait tour G4
bien joué F prend6 il veut tour prend C4
il reste sensiblement mieux donc c'est
défendu et maintenant H5 oh il se fait
enfermer le fou terrible
ah c'est terrible mais c'est peut-être
pas fait encore incroyable tour C1 il va
prendre
C4 il joue C6 attention le pion va venir
en
D6 mais bon il veut roi
D7 est-ce qu'il va réussir à la tenir
lur dit et ophé
mais rien n'est
sûr le pion qui avance vite quand même
sur tour3 il y a tour B3
échec il va mettre le pion
A3 tour G2 il va mettre la tour en D4 je
pense il fait tour à4 tour
g76 sur D7 a tour
D4 il va la gagner y ou pas
il a raté
fou5 il y a la tour qui vient en A7 le
roi qui doit revenir en F7 le roi qui
doit venir en E6 à tout prix et ça y est
je crois qu'il arrête le pion mais
encore ro E4 qui peut faire mal mais ro4
tour à 4 donc il fait fou F4 A2
maintenant tour H6 roi D5 le roi qui va
vers
C4 non il revient vers
E6 je pense qu'il va y avoir un
statuco et une nulle plutôt mérité ah il
fait tour5 quand
même ro F6 ah c'est bordel ah il réussit
à ah il réussit à récupérer le pion à de
et on va avoir un roit tour contre
contre roitour quelle partie mesdames et
messieurs mais c'est pas sûr qu'il gagne
le pion on l' vu dans une partie à pas
longtemps dans dans ce même tournoi il
faut pas donner le pion gratuitement là
il ne faut pas donner ce pion
gratuitement
il faut le garder en
C5 le plus longtemps possible ou en C4
mais je il faut le garder en V à faire
C3 je
pense il faut il faut le garder en vie
parce qu'il est pas facile à gagner tour
C4 je pense juste et mettre en C2 et
personne pourra jamais te le prendre en
fait il y aura forcément échange quand
il sera
manger je pense pas qu'on puisse il
aurait pu faire tour C5
là ah il va vouloir mettre le fou en C3
il va réussir à l'attraper en
fait il va réussir à
l'attraper très bien
joué bon après il part de loin là Yan
il part de
loin mais quelle partie quel bras de
fer quel bras de
fer BR faire incroyable de la part des
deux
hommes ça c'est les parties d'échec
qu'on aime voir les deux les deux jouent
pour le gain jusqu'au bout mais je sens
fébrile hein je le sens d'une
fébrilité je le sens très fébrile
là il va peut-être faire la défense sur
la 7e ou
pas allez roi F5 peut-être part vers le
grand
côté il va mettre la tour en F6 ah je le
sens d'une fébrilité
ah là je sens le setup se mettre en
place là c'est
terrible Yan qui a réussi à avancer ça
commence à quel coup je vais je vais
vous dire hein ça
fait ça fait que 20 coups
là allez il faut la tenir là attendez
j'ai eu un bug est-ce que j'espère que
ça
pas ça a impacté les pendules attendez
les pendues marche plus on va les
remettre ça va on a le temps pendant
pendant ce moment un peu
fébrile je pense que c'est revenu
ouais ça fait flipper mais bon il a mis
il a mis une bonne une bonne défense
allez il peut faire un
échec il va mettre la tour en C8 en en
F1
ouais allez c'est
bien mais Yan qui a réussi à déconnecter
la défense de la 7e
rangée il va faire tour
ok il veut bloquer sur la 7e de
nouveau Yan qui est
chiant mais la défense 7e qui fonctionne
qui veut montrer qu'il a fait des progrs
en finale en
plus je pense qu' va faire ro F8
ici il revient c'est pas mal joué
ok t B7 c'est
bien allez Miss alle maintenant faut la
jouer il faut
punir maintenant c'est Alireza de jouer
le
gain et ça fait rire Yan et ça fait rire
Alireza ça fait rire Yan et
alia Yann qui va aller dans le
coin et voilà il a fait la technique de
défense on n pas accè à la case G3 en
fait c'est ça le
problème a fou C7 tour G7 et le problème
c'est qu'il a fou H2 il fait juste t H2
et ça va faire
nul bien défendu hein il a il a tous les
deux eu ils ont tous les deux eu les
techniques de
défense bonne partie a rien à dire 162
coups pour commencer ça pense à la
cillass des streamers côté côté
joueurs c'est bien merci à
vous là il jouent pour la Cillas des
streamers hein c'est évident ça joue
pour la killass là ils font durer le
plaisir ouais c'était
marrant Miss clic sans conséquence he
pour pour
Yan en tout cas c'était
marrant en tout cas c'était vraiment
marrant comme
partie ça va se lever côté côté
Yan côté alierzam c'était une partie
vraiment amusante au moins on a bien
rigoler à la
fin
ENF la partie était vraiment
amusante non je crois qu'il a mise clic
ou il a voulu jouer tempo en fait
peut-êre qu'il a voulu pré y pour mettre
en danger de toute façon il savait que
s'il donnait une tour c'était pas grave
hein fr avant tout il veut mettre bien
LEF et
oui
en tout cas il rigole je sais pas trop
ce qui se passe
bon la partie était vraiment
cool franchement j'ai kiffé cette game
et c'est ce genre de partie qu'on espère
voir dans ces
tournois c'est ce genre de match qu'on
espère avoir
après dernière après capure oua mais je
pense pas qu'il avait les les coups ah
intéressant il rejoue la même que que
celle qu'ils ont eu en tournoi il y a
pas longtemps qu'on avait analysé avec
Mathieu ces deux hommes se retrouveront
bien évidemment en avril au candidat
en tout cas très très beau combat dans
la première partie je suis
content je suis
heureux qui pas de conséquen sur un M
clic oui
d'accord
et là il joue G4 intéressant ce
G4 pour revenir tout de suite
taper et donc il joue la dame en
B6
ok c'est complexe hein est-ce qu'il va
jouer cavalier
A4 je pense pas qu'il veut jouer
cavalier A4 peut-être dame D2 et sur
dame prend B2 tour B1 ça c'est possible
hein dame ah mais dame D2 qui prend G4
euh
ouais alors le seul coup d'après l'ORD
c'est tour B1 mais on est en arrivé là
aussi hein puisqueau final si on peut
pas jouer dam B2 à cause dame D2 à cause
de kg4 que sur G5 à Dame prend B2
intermédiaire et cavalier A4 il va jouer
dame à 5 échec et mettre son cavalier en
E4 la conclusion c'est qu'il y a plus
que tourb1 c'est pas un coup qu'on a
envie de jouer mais après si c'est le
seul coup c'est le seul coup
hein si c'est le seul coup c'est le seul
coup
si c'est seul coup c'est le seul coup
bon j'ai 6 H4 hein il va faire H4 H5 H6
ça va être marrant comme
partie
queochens vous donner une information
rosé Martinez Alcantara vient de changer
de fédération lui qu'on avait suivi dans
ce tournoi il passe de la Fédération
péruvienne à celle de Mexico du
Mexique ce qui me met extrêmement bien
joueur du cartel avant
tout c'est une très belle info que je
vous
lâche
je sais pas sil va jouer H4 Contin dans
l'idée fou g ouais là il y a plein de
coups possi la position est vraiment
extrêmement
chaotique il fait fou G2 fou2 j'aime
bien aussi c'est juste logique
il joue
H3 cavalier
F3
leord dit d'un H5 comme meilleur coup
mais j'y crois pas du
tout je n'y crois absolument pas oh la
position est tellement chaotique
j'adore j'adore on peut difficilement
avoir une position plus
complexe
on peut difficilement avoir plus
complexe damass il veut empêcher le rock
l'ordi aime pas trop mais c'est vrai que
c'est
enfin moi visuellement c'est pas un coup
que j'aurais aimé après ça aurait pu
être très fort mais après j l'aime pas
trop mais bon c'est gentil
hein la barre a quasiment pas évoluer
mais il veut peut-être aussi jouer
cavalier B6 c'est intéressant comme coup
en
réalité j'adore le le coup de lordordi
qui est pas le premier mais dame D3
parce que sur dame prend P on prend on
regagne le contrôle du centre donc ça
c'est vraiment un coup hyper intéressant
dam
des3 ah dame D3 c'est vraiment un joli
coup parce que dame prend pion prend
ouais c'est le coup joué j'adore ce
coup
ah j'adore ce coup dame D3 dame prend D3
pion prend D3 et on vient recontrôler la
case
4 ah ça c'est un coup qui est vraiment
fort il fait B6 pour pour se pour se
protéger mais du coup il s'enlève
cavalier
B6 et cavalier5 ouais c'est un c'est un
joli un joli enchaînement là alors comme
vous voyez hein c'est c'est pas ça qui
fait gagner la partie évidemment mais
c'est ça qui fait que c'est lui qui a la
position la plus agréable et à noter que
maintenant des coups comme B4 B5 peuvent
faire mal pour venir fracasser l'Andy
muré voyez ici un petit Andy muré
ambulant qui qui a apparu sur sur le
terrain et on peut éventuellement
envoyer le pion B en Beller justement
pour pour le
détruire
il joue cavalie
8 et peut-être qu'il va prendre en G7 et
jouer rock
après alors dame prend 6 on va
absolument pas le jouer parce que ça
développerait le fou
adverse al là la question c'est est-ce
qu'on veut se laisser prendre en E5 ou
pas on peut se laisser prendre pour
avoir ce pion qui contrôle les cases
il a joué B4 ouais c'est vraiment le
coup logique pour jouer B5 et et venir
taper avec le fou G2 c'est pour le
moment une très jolie partie rondement
menée par alirea
firouja B4 fait mal hein B4 fait très
très mal
ah la prise d'espace est massive et en
plus ça vient un peu justifier
positionnement de la tour en
B1 et donc préparer
B5 très jolie très jolie
partie c'est magnifique là ce qui est en
train de se jouer et Yan qui commence à
être mal au temps enfin mal a temp je
commence à être à à revenir au temp sur
sur alirea mais simplement il a pas la
position donc il fait E6 il renforce
mais maintenant il bloque son fou et je
pense qu'alira va en profiter pour jouer
H4 un coup à gauche un coup à
droite H4 H5 wou ça arrive de vraiment
de tous les côtés alors est-ce qu'on
commence par foupr
G7 je pense qu'il va jouer H4 ici pour
moi l'ordinateur lui il kiffe petit ro
mais ça va pas être petit ro le coup ici
je pense pas qu'alireza joue un coup de
temporisation comme
celui-là je pense vraiment que ça va
être H4
H5 il a fait G5 c'est dans le même
esprit après est-ce que on peut jouer
fou prend pion prend en sachant qu'après
dame prend pion prend va se prendre un
énorme mur blanc qui va contrôler toutes
les cases noires de
l'chiquier après il peut décider de
prendre peut-être et prendre
D3 et jouer c'est ouis je sais pas
j'aime pas la position des noirs
malira qui met une nouvelle fois Yan au
supplice avec ce D4 D5 cavalier C3 il va
vraiment être obligé de l'étudier pour
les candidat Yan cette ouverture parce
que là il se prend du bouillon il prend
le bouillon Yan nepomyashi dans dans ce
dans ce cavalier C3 D4 on rappelle
qu'era a déjà battu avec cette arme
au en partie longue à
Vaze et là il est en train de de faire
bis repétit de le remettre une grosse
pression et oui je vous avais dit he le
temps de Yan je sentais que ça allait
aller de mal en P et ça y est il échange
en E5 alors c'est peut-être bien joué
hein c'est le moment et cavalier
C7 et là ça va jouer H4 côté côté alirea
H4 c'est un bon coup ça vient protéger
le le pion c'est un coup qui est de
toute façon utile H4 voilà ça re
reconsolide la structure c'est c'est
magnifique c'est magnifique ce que fait
Alireza et attention peut-être
maintenant que dame D4 peut être une
idée pour aller jouer l'attaque de mat
ça peut forcer y à prendre mais siil
prend
la structure va être va être dégueulasse
mais il est peut-être il est peut-être
contraint et forcé he de jouer cette
finale il veut pas en tout cas il veut
pas Yan la jouer mais ça peut aller vite
hein dame D4 H5 dame H4 puis on prend et
damage 7 ma c'est 1 2 3 4 coups c'est
matant 4 alors après sur dame D4 tu
auras encore des dames C4 mais oui il
est il est obligé de venir de venir la
prendre il s'accroche pour le moment y a
au branches et là H5 peut être une idée
parce que sur pion prend tour prend on
attire la tour en H4 pour aller jouer
l'attaque de
mat mais je pense qu'il va jouer à 3
simplement pour essayer de fixer la
faiblesse en B6 en C6
pardon va PE peut-être tenter un échange
et peut-être de jouer du C5 après là
encore un énorme combat entre les deux
hommes vraiment de très très belles
parties très agréable à suivre ce
match je pense qu'il va jouer à 3 plus
sécurisant H5 évidemment le coup
ambitieux par
excellence il hésite hein il hésite
c'est sûr qu'il a les les deux coups en
tête il en calcule un des deux àirea H5
c'est le coup tentant c'est le coup
maximaliste et c'est joué mais c'est du
al resa tout craché là qu'on a en ce
moment il retrouve son niveau hein il
retrouve il retrouve son brillant al H5
le coup le plus agressif de la
[Musique]
position
Yan sous les sous les coups de bambou là
d'alirea il a d il a du taf à faire pour
tenir le demi-point et aller en
Armagedon il va falloir qu'il s'emploie
yanpomashi pour rester dans ce
match allez qui fait mal qui fait même
très mal fou des7 et maintenant
peut-être il va faire pion prend pion
prend et tour
B7 à mon avis maintenant c'est l'heure
de
prendre sur la prise de la tour on
pourra prendre en B6 et sur la prise du
pion aller peut-être se glisser jusqu'en
B7 ça a l'air fort alors pourquoi l'ordi
n'aime pas parce qu'il y a le coup B5
extraordinaire coup de défense c'est le
seul coup surpion prend à 5 ah est-ce
que Yan va le trouver le seul coup pour
pour rester avec
égalité ah ça va être trouvé par y ça va
être trouvé contre un efforcé de l'avoir
mais bon B5 à4 encore la position va
être désagréable à jouer pour pour le
joueur russe plus 4 minutes pour lui 414
pour Alireza une toute petite pression
au temps qui se construit Yan qui
s'accroche
encore mais B5 ça va être à 4 He c'est
sûr B5 c'est à 4 instantané
pour le champion français allez 30
secondes d'avance ça commence à
parler ça peut faire une différence dans
une position très complexe qui arrivera
Alera qui aura le temps de poser encore
une minute de réflexion peut-être là où
Yan sera obligé de de se dépêcher en
tout cas il hésite on prend à 5 B prend
à 5 B5 il y a trois coup à calculer il y
a trois
possibilités c'est compliqué allez une
minute d'écart quasiment maintenant A5
B5 trouvé évidemment tour B4
qui joue à tempo qui veut aller jouer
l'attaque de mat ça fait mal le tour B4
à tempo ici a a a en difficulté T4 fait
mal là on prend
H5 et là il va jouer
tour4 mais y qui veut défendre avec ro
G7 et tour
H8 alors est-ce que est-ce que il va
aller jouer pour cavalier2 cavalier F4
après est-ce qu'il va aller jouer pour
cavalier2 cavalier
F4 H47 cavalier2 à mon avis c'est ça la
ligne B4 ro G7 cavalier2 puis cavalier
F4 cavalier prend H5 et cavalier F6
l'ordinateur préfère cavalier
directement mais je pense pas que ce
soit le le coup il fait tour
H5 alors ça c'était une erreur
bizarrement pas bizarrement en fait
parce que il y a pas de raison de faire
ce coup tour BH4 tour H8 il a raté le le
plan avec cavalier2 cavalier F4 il était
certes pas simple mais c'est un c'est un
raté côté côté
al alors est-ce qu'on peut jouer tour H4
tour H8 D4 tour prend5 fou F il fait
cavalier de mainant et ouais mais c'est
dommage parce que on voulait prendre
avec le cavalier on va perdre un tempo
précieux on perd un coup précieux ici
et surtout sur sur cavalier F4
maintenant directement il va y avoir du
C5 donc il passe par G3 ouais c'est bien
joué au moins sur C5 on a tour
H4 la partie est loin d'être terminée
très loin d'être terminée les
amis c'est juste on sent que là du coup
si l'idée c'était de venir prendre on
sent que ce coup de tour était
superflu ce pion on le gardait sous
pression tout de façon il était prenable
à n'importe quel coup il s'est un petit
peu précipité dessus allez plus 3
minutes 01 contre
241 visuellement ça reste un bel
avantage blanc ne vous fiez pas à la
barre d'évaluation mais il faut quand
même noter que les noirs sont à tour pr
à 2 C5 B4 B3 B2 B1 de gagner la partie
hein donc c'est il y a du jeu des deux
côtés c'est pour ça qu'un temps gagné ou
perdu est si précieux dans ces positions
là parce que c'est 1 2 3 4 5 6 coups et
les Noirs ont gagné donc les BL un de
ils ont le temps d'aller mat et donc il
vera un et puis il y aura tour H8 puis
tour H6 puis cavalier H5 puis cavalier
F6 enfin ça va ça va être chaud donc il
prend le pion A2 là on s'attend
mais s'il fait tour H2 en fait il perd
il aura perdu un temps net mais ouais en
fait tour H1 enfin la tour H1 on peut
pas le faire par qu' a tour A1 mais on
comprend qu'on a envie de reculer la
tour pour pour pour mettre le cavalier
en H5 donc on comprend qu'on aurait fait
1 2 3 4 4 5 et là on va faire 1 2 3 4
5 non mais on a perdu un temps j'ai mal
compté les C on a forcément perdu un
temps puisque on a on a joué deux coups
de tour au lieu d'en jouer que un j'ai
fait n'importe quoi en analysant mais
c'est pas grave ouais mais c'est le
temps le temps il est hyper compliqué là
qu'on a qu'on a perdu il est hyper
important est-ce qu'on peut jouer tour
F4 C5 fou 3 B4 fou
H5 B3 ça va vite donc tour H4 il y a pas
B4 pour le moment et sur C5 il y a tour
H7 tour H7 tour H7 B4 G6
B3 tour F7 3 D8 G7 B2 G8 dame et com
bien même là ce serait pas fini parce
qu'après fou E8 on peut pas arrêter le
pion adverse vous voyez un peu la
complexité des
lignes évidemment ce sont des lignes
absolument pas correcte que je calcule
hein il y a plein d'autres coups mais
c'est pour montrer donc là il va faire
tour H7 je pense tour H7 tour H7 B4 G6
B3 G7 B2 G8 B1 dam
mat donc il peut
pas donc fou
F3
C5 tour H7 tour H7 tour H7 B4 fou
D1 c'est C4 pion prend pision prend G6
je sais pas c'est hyper
compliqué c'est peut-être en train de
tourner en faveur de Yan
étonnamment je seraai quand même plutôt
partisan de fou F3 fou D1
personnellement qui est pas qui est pas
le principal de l'UR mais je serais
quand
même partisan de ça mais alors pourquoi
après il fait Tourp H7 Tourp H7 TP H7
B4 il veut quoi il veut cavalier
E8 B3 qui est D6 B2 tour F7 et il y a un
perpète et cavalier E8
cavalier G6 B3 P F7 P2 euh ouais c'est
l'enfer c'est
l'enfer en fait là il a deux options
soit il prend E8 avec des idées
d'essayer de ramener la tour par
derrière soit il fait fou F3
ouis c'est ce qu'il fait pour jouer fou
D1 et fou C2 et arrêter le pion il prend
E8 alors maintenant sur cavalier prend 8
a G6 B3 tour F7 et tour B7 je
crois
et bon quand même il y aurait B2 roi D1
tour à1 roi
C2
l'enfer et donc sur B3 il y a cavalier
D6 B2 tour prend F7 roi D8 tour F8 roi
E7 est
nul
à çair qu'on peut faire cavalier D6 B2
tour F7 roi D8 tour F8 ro E7 et tour B8
tour A1 bouff bouff et F4 ah mais je
pense qu'il va la jouer hein ah mais
tour B8 il a cavalier B5
ah oh ça peut être
raté non c'est pas
raté t B8 a cavalier
B5 ça peut être ataté parce qu'on peut
vouloir s'embarquer dans l' truc mais
cavalier B5 tiens non c'est
vu et ça va faire
nul quelle partie de fou furieux W le
match est incroyable un partout mais
voilà c'est ça les échecs qu'on voulait
voir en finale du tournoi c'est ce c'est
ce genre de partie qui qui fait le
charme de de cette compétition
et ouais il a fallu d'attendre d'avoir
deux joueurs de haut niveau l'un contre
l'autre ça joue peut-être un petit peu
moins bien
que c'est un peu moins précis que que
que d'autres mais mais c'est des beaux
échecs et donc ça va être l'arma
Guedon match assez extraordinaire pour
le
moment match assez extraordinaire et
donc tout va se jouer sur
l'armagedon mais ça c'est vraiment voilà
les parties que qu'on avait envie de
voir depuis depuis le jour 1 en réalité
ouais partie partie vraiment
extraordinaire hein
très très très belle partie deux très
belles parties deux deux
parties vraiment très très agréable à à
suivre deux parties réellement
extraordinaires
moins précis que les chouchous peut-être
mais mais très
agréable y est bien deg ouais bon après
il a pas de ils ont ils ont fait de
belles parties et là on va avoir
le la
dernière
l'Armageddon à enchère les blancs auront
plus de temps et les Noirs seront
obligés de
gagner telle est la dure vie des échecs
mais là on kiffe là on kiffe dommage
qu'on ait pas eu ça depuis le le premier
jour parce que là c'est un
plaisir là c'est un réel plaisir
ouais j'espère que firou les noir pas
sûr hein je sais pas là ça dépend
vraiment du du
temps ça dépend vraiment du
temps ça dépend vraiment du temps que
que les joueurs
auront
disons que à 630 contre 10 je prendrais
plutôt les blancs par exemple dans ce
match surtout qu'il y a pas de
rajou donc moi j'irai plutôt
sur on va dire par jusqu'à 730 c'est
discutable je pense qu'en dessous c'est
mieux d'avoir les les les
blancs il y a qui dans l' demi alors il
y a pas d'aut demi en fait c'est tableau
de c'est tableau un peu bizarre ces
tableau de de loser bracket mais en fait
celui qui est en demi celui qui a perdu
en enfin celui qui a perdu en finale
c'est la
zavic
on va voir on va
voir quelle heure
l'Armageddon je sais là là ils font le
le tirage au sort enfin le tirage au
sort les enchères je pense dans 5
minutes
bon on
attend on attend je sais pas trop quoi
vous dire tu bien ça un peu bizarre avec
winner loser bracket
euh je reste pas complètement fan parce
que
[Musique]
je trouve que ce serait bien mais qu'il
y a pas assez de joueurs pour que ça
fasse vraiment
sens mais je suis pas complètement
opposé non plus je suis pas complètement
opposé on va dire ça comme
ça
on attend on
attend on ne peut qu'attendre de toute
façon
ok mon ça boit un peu
d'eau
tu penses quoi il parti à l'aveugle
aur-tu un conseil de visation des cases
c'est pas mal comme entraînement pour
s'entraîner à visualiser les
chiquers après c'est pas forcément
indispensable moi je le faisais avant
enfin je l'ai eu fait avant mais c'est
pas un entraînement
obligatoire comme tous les trucs que tu
peux faire ça va te faire progress Esser
mais ça dépend de ton niveau ça dépend
de beaucoup de
choses
je pense ça va bientôt
partir la partie ça doit être ça je
crois qu'alira va avoir les Noirs mais B
je suis pas sûr on n'est jamais sûr avec
ça allez si c'est parti il a bien les
Noirs il a pris 654 donc je vous avais
dit auudessus de 730 c'était pour moi de
sûr que les blancs que les Noirs étaient
bien en dessous de de 6 j'allais dit
c'était sûr que les Blancs étaient bien
et du coup bah lourcher ça était 656
comme quoi le commentateur n'a pas dit
n'importe quoi les joueurs ont dû avoir
la même sensation entre 630 et 730
c'était c'était la
vérité bon on a cette position qui
ressemble un petit peu à à ce que Yan
avait bien joué contre Ding ouh là ça
c'est une gaffe oh non oh non regardez
ce qu'il a raté Irat fou prend F2 ro
prend F2 et dame C5 non mais c'est trop
oh
incroyable incroyable ce qu' viennent de
rater trois fois d'affilé oh là là là là
là là oh l'enchaînement de gaff aucun
des deux ne l'a vu non mais c'est
incroyable ça à ce niveau de la
compétition
incroyable le triple raté oh là là al
Rea il peut s'en vouloir il peut s'en
mordre les doigts ah fou prend F2 dame
C5 dame prend B5 c'était terminé
instantanément incroyable d'avoir raté
quelque chose d'aussi simple eux qui qui
sont capables du meilleur ah je suis je
suis accablé là on croir une sub battle
ah ils viennent de rater l'immancable à
trois fois en plus les
deux ah Franch frchement c'est
étonnant c'est étonnant c'est venu comme
une surprise en fait que qui est ce fou
F2 dame C5 il a raté une fois une
deuxième
fois allez il faut quand même tenir
sinon il y aura des regrets hein pour
Alireza il y aura d'énormes
regrets
ah c'est c'est j'arrive pas à en revenir
encore
ais c'est parce que c'est l'Armageddon
il y a pas de rajout de temps donc on
veut jouer plus vite
et ah c'est incroyable ils sont capables
de voir des choses tellement
complexes et là il rate il rate une
tactique simple de 1300 ho et pas une
fois c'est alira qui a raté deux fois y
tro fois et quand il a fait à 4 il a
même pas vu qu'il l'a
défendait ah ils s'en sont pas rendu
compte il y a pas eu de grimace ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre aucun des deux ne l'a
vu
ou les gaffes arrivent pour certains en
tout
cas ah c'est incroyable le F F2 et dam
C5 c'était vraiment pas compliqué après
nous c'est plus facile on a on a les les
signes de gaffe mais quand même en
partie normalement si tu le rates une
fois tu le vois tout de suite après tu
le fait au coup d'après ça c'est c'est
étonnant qui a toujours une position
correcte
a a a a a a a j'arrive j'ai du mal à
m'en
remettre
cavalier3 si on prend à4 et sur dame
prend à 4 cavalier
E5 il va vouloir mettre le cavalier en
D3 bon c'est très maîtrisé he de la part
d'All
c'est c'est du facile pour le moment là
c'est tour fd8 franchement la position
elle est elle est royale pour le
français
elle est royale là pour
alirea c'est vraiment avantage noir ça
se voit il y a toutes les cases et puis
je vous rappelle on a juste besoin d'une
nulle pour gagner 2 minutes de retard
encore mais bon il a
520 c'est encore très conséquent Yan va
avoir du mal à poser des problèmes ici
après on sent les joueurs un petit peu
fatigués un petit peumouss par un
combat intense jusque là tour le
cavalier qui va jaillir en D3 côté al
alors veut commencer par T PR1 qui est
beaucoup plus fort en
fait et maintenant tour D8 il est il est
facile d 4 B6 le pion B6 complètement
défendu
51 qui gère sa pendule comme un prince
Yan qui est en train de le rattraper
gentiment dans une mauvaise position y
mauvaise posture allez F B6 à tempo
parfait alirea il est propre pour le
moment dans cette partie il est très
très
propre il est très très propre alirea
part cette
gaffe et là le cavalier arrive en D3 au
next sur cavalier C4 il y a même
cavalier prend et tour D1 mais cavalier
C4 c'est un coup qu'on regarde est-ce
qu'il y a pas quelque chose de plus fort
que ça
OK prend C4 prend C4 il y a dame G3
mesdames et messieurs ça ça a l'air
vraiment fort
ouais sur k C4 k prend4 dame prend C4
dame G3 dame 2 il y aura même du tour1
Tour tour D1 à mon
avis qui doit faire très très
mal y qui rattrape al petit à petit plus
que 61 contre
fou de qui D3 fou
C4 cavalier D3 aussi fou de cavalier D3
tout
bêtement là c'est vraiment
cadeau fou prend P on prend
ouis c'est du facile c'est du très très
facile faut surtout prendre du pion Làa
faut pas hésiter
t prend c'est peut-être une
faute pu on prend ça avait l'air d'être
très entreprenant quand
même il avait peur de se faire fixer par
par fou des de j'imagine mais bon ça
paraissait tellement logique de prendre
du pion et de de
l'approcher bon la position reste super
bonne dame C2 il va remettre la dame en
D6 ou en D7 ou en
D8 non pas d D6 ah mais cavalier C4 il a
tour D1
ouais tout
marche dame D7 peut-être même plus
simple pour fou prend dame prend
F5 ce qu'il faut c'est
jouer ce qu'il faut c'est jouer mesdames
et
messieurs c'est pas encore
fait il faut jouer dame des7 jouer ça
donne un peu un gain de pion potentiel C
dame
2 je sais pas ce qu'il peut vouloir en
fait ti je vois pas comment il peut
améliorer sa position j'imagine qu'alira
va jouer cavalier D5
ici il prend des5 pion prend des5 même
ouais c'est ça donc il va jouer cavalier
C4 est-ce qu'on a cavalier prend C3 si
on prend C3 tour D1 ro
H2 non F C 7
G3 il va jouer calier C4 cavalier C4 fou
C7 alors sur dame pr 4 il auras tourd un
mat cavalier C4 fou
C7 et sur G3 ouais on pourra aller
prendre F5 allez 403 contre 453 plus que
50 secondes de retard c'est important de
de recoller
autant
puisque nul
gagne je le rappelle et donc si ça peut
plus jouer le flag de l'autre côté non
plus c'est tout BF mais surtout
psychologiquement de plus avoir ce
retard à la pendule ça fait du
bien il a les Noirs il est
mieux nul gagne et il y a plus de
problème autant tous les voyants sont au
vert qui fait cavalier G4 alors il veut
dame prend F5 fou prend H6 on connaitt
le marlou c'est vu instantanément
évidemment côté Alire Rea alors la
variante de l'ordi pourquoi c'est une
faute c'est Dame F5 FO H6 et G5 qui ne
va pas être joué parce que beaucoup trop
risqué par rapport à la situation mais
c'est très fort parce que ça enchaîne
avec cavalier F4 je ne pense pas que ça
va être joué par alirea c'est pas les
coups qu'on regarde quand on doit faire
nul il menace cavalier
E5 et c'est pour ça qu'il le joue quand
même mais voilà il a pas G5 il joue dame
e 6 après G5 était vraiment difficile il
joue dame 6 qui est le le truc le plus
safe il se met en diagonale du cavalier
il y aura jamais de
fourchette et il maintient ouais il veut
F5 F4
f3in il veut F4 F5 F3 Yan qui avait
toujours ses 30 secondes d'avance allez
il faut pas qu'il les amène jusqu'au
bout ces 30 secondes d'avance parce que
si on a 30 secondes contre une minute là
ça deviendra dangereux donc il faut euh
recoller petit à petit au temps un peu
comme comme dans le cyclisme revenir
graduellement sur
l'adversaire là Yan va jouer il va
forcer à la réflexion c'est pour ça que
même si on a égalisé on va on va avoir
une période de réflexion derrière il va
jouer F6 je
pense pour chasser ce
fou
333 pour les blancs faut pas trop
traîner he comme je vous disais il faut
faut pas laisser cette avance autant
épaissir F6 fou
E3 alirea va être tenté de tout échanger
en E3 il va faire cavalier prend E3
cavalier prend E3 fou prend E3 et dame
des5 c'est trop
logique vu la situation de
match il va y avoir tour F1 ici sur tour
d de il va faire
dame G4 et il y aura plus
F5 il va essayer d'aller à monceler
là-bas des des
pièces il fait B4 d'abord ah c'est bien
joué parce que B4 il veut essayer de set
up un puis on prend tour à 8 peut-être
au H7 dam H5 qui marche pas
encore donc AB AB CB ça va être joué
dame G5
maintenant il va y avoir tour E1 à mon
avis
ouais c'est bien joué de la part de Yan
par rapport à la position qu'il avait
évidemment he là les noirs sont mieux
mais il a essayé d'accepter les
échanges et là il y a une difficulté
pour alirea c'est qu'il aimerait bien
juste passer son tour je pense à mon
avis il va jouer roi
F8 pour s'enlever de tous les échecs sur
case blanche et redonner le trait à Yan
parce que roi F8 c'est dur de bouger
hein
à vrai dire sur ro F8 le meilleur coup
c'est ro
G1 ro F pour moi c'est cadeau ah il le
fait pas la ro F8 est tellement logique
ça enlève dame à de échec ça enlève
tout oh non pourquoi il le joue pas il
fait G6 bon il veut mettre le RO en G7
c'est pas mal aussi c'est dans c'est
dans la même idée c'est dans la même
idée c'est la même chose en mieux ou en
aussi bien mais bon il va faire dame à
de 2 roi G7 tour F1 ouais c'était sûr
c'était sûr qu'il allait faire ça t
prend le3 va jouer dame C4 non il fait
ro G7 d'abord c'est bien joué ro G7
parce que du coup il y a pas sur sur
dame dame C2 tour il va faire dame C2 il
fait dame B2 dame B2 dame D6 on défend
tout menace tour D1 là quand même pour
nul ah j'ai pas aimé he ce G6 quand même
ça affaibli ce pion il veut surt reprend
le TR ah il veut dame à 7 donc il va
jouer G5 C G6 là
lireza
ah il s'est mis dans le problème tout
seul là il va faire G5 C faut jouer là
134 il y a plus de rajou oh il a pas
l'air d'être au courant RA oh il
sue il y a plus de rajou là il faut
jouer
ah mais il doit jouer ah mais la seule
manière de perdre c'est de pas jouer
hein oh là là là allez G5 jouer c'était
pas le coup de l'ordi c'était mon coup
perso c'est pas un coup difficile mais
il faut jouer il faut mettre le r G6
essayer peut-être de pousser peut-être
pas de pousser mais de toute façon il a
tourd allez faut monter le RO en G6 là
faut
jouer dame F2 tour D1 tour D1 dame F5 tu
recules allez bien joué ça ro G7 voilà
parfait parfait parfait
parfait ah c'est dommage il a vraiment
jeté 30 secondes à la poubelle là j'ai 5
crois6 c'était vraiment la
facilité et maintenant juste trquer les
pions et faire nul hein le perpète là il
a il a bien joué il a bien géré la
situation en réalité juste il pourrait
avoir encore une 30 ou une 35 avec
exactement la même position et 30
secondes c'est beaucoup parce que là il
a un problème Yan en fait c'est ouais
tour G1 benah on va prendre et dame
prend B4 il peut rien arriver hein c'est
il ne peut rien arriver arver il peut
aller gagner C6 s'il veut mais roi G6
dame C6 dame 1 il ne peut rien arriver
ici on a un pion de plus il suffit juste
de mettre la dame en D5 c'est terminé he
bah voilà dame C4 on protège tout il ne
peut rien arriver dame dame C4 dame D5
pourquoi il réfléchit réfléchis pas JEE
met à dam en D5 il ne peut rien
t'arriver c'est impossible tu as un pion
de plus tu fais ro G7 ro G6 donc il va
essayer de te faire tomber mais tu mets
juste ta dam en D5 et tu fais C5 c'est 4
et merci je pense pas qu'il essaye y
là à mon avis il va être
fairplay non ben prends juste tu prends
mais joue vite hein joue vite hein bah
allez dam des 5 juste les coups
logiques h G6 hos G7 juste la logique ro
H4 dame G5 dame E3 et c'est
ciao et ben dame G5
pourquoi tu fais pas dame G5 pour dame
G3 bah dame G5 dame E4 dame F5 et c'est
c'est nul tout de suite et Yan qui est
dégoûté il a le seum là on échange les
dames dame
F5 ro
E4 ro H5 ro E3 roi G6 ro F4 ro F6 ro G3
la nulle est accepté et alirea qui se
qualifie Yan éliminé de ce tournoi et
alza qui remonte petite à petit la pente
dans ce braquet des laosé il est
maintenant en
finale contre lazavic Yan qui est un
petit peu
dégoûté alira qui qui revient petit à
petit dans ce tournoi il est il est dans
les trois derniers et maintenant on va
arriver on va arriver à la finale bien
évidemment
on va arriver à la finale des
perdants Yan complètement écuré qui
discute il a le se grosso modo je crois
que c'est ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'il a le se
c'est parfait c'est parfait ce qui nous
a fait
alirea il nous sort rien du
tournoi
et maintenant il suffit plus que
d'éliminer laavic alors laav plus fort
que y bien évidemment là c'est l'Everest
qui Dr sur la route d' mais gag pour
aller chercher notre am Magnus en finale
pour un match très plaisant suiv
mercredi
psychologiquement il a battu le Reb ici
il lui fait mal
ça va être maintenant contre la zavic
alors je pense qu'il y a une vraie pause
au moins d'un quart d'heure à mon avis
pour laisser le temps à à Alera de
récupérer mais c'est une très belle
qualification
en tout cas là c'est la
pause la zavi qui est en train d'arriver
ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on fasse
nous aussi une petite
pause ça va pas reprendre immédiatement
de toute façon ils vont donner au moins
10 minutes je pense à à lirea donc on se
retrouve très vite pour pour la finale
du loser bracket du tableau des perdants
ou comme j'aime bien l'appeler le losé
braqué merci à
tous quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échiken
Surpat du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speed chess ou les
title Tuesday
chess.com/events courv tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tbles
base retrouvez toutes les infos
essentiels comme le programme les
horaires des rondes les prix les
résultats les contreendus quotidien les
bios des joueurs les règles departage et
plus encore vous pouvez même participer
à la compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
jess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle par ailleur
[Musique]
alors attendez on va on va on va
reprendre tout de suite que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a peut-être un
souci en fait je vois pas les parties
mais j'aiimession que les joueurs jouent
attende on a les cam à l'envers déjà on
va se remettre à
l'endroit j'ai pris une petite pause le
match était quand même assez intense
on va remettre les scores comme il
faut non non ça a pas ça a pas repris ça
a pas
repris
ok non ça a pas
repris je sais pas quelle heure ça
reprend
précisément jamais
simple allez ça part
donc fait une
italienne donc al est blanc on a les
bonnes couleurs et il joue H3 c'est un
des multiples
coups ok
H3 il va jouer C3 je pense il va y avoir
à 6 ou à 5 il va faire à 4
je dis qu'il va faire ce coupl parce que
c'est les coups qu'on voit
toujours après lazavic solide he il va
être très très dur à à
battre je lazavic plus dangereux que NPO
pour moi oui he il a eu des il a des
meilleurs résultats que que Yan sur
Internet lazavic après y n'est pas
toujours en trayard sur internet non
plus mais il a de très très gros
résultats c'est un des tout meilleurs
joueurs du monde la
zavic dans ces formats de fou F 7 fou
B3 il va jouer pour cavalier F1 alors
est-ce qu'il peut décider de jouer un
truc avec G4 comme il vient de le faire
contre Yan alors c'était pas une
italienne hein mais qu'il peut décider
de retarder le rock de venir placer le
cavalier vers
E3 peut-être mettre le fou en
E3
on va voir la
zavic dur à
jouer donc si alira gagne ce match il
rencontrera Magnus Carlsen
mercredi pour une finale alléchante et
j'ai envie de
dire final
alléchante cavalier
F1 il veut jouer fou G5
potentiellement Dame des de et grand
rock je pense qu'il veut jouer un truc
comme ça je pense qu'il vaut se faire
kiffer de façon dans ce match contre
laavi il a bien
raison
F G5 en plus sur cavalier G3 aussi ouais
non c'est ça a l'air intéressant là ce
qu' fait
ala plus que 8 minutes pour la
zavic déjà sous
pression je pense qu' réfléchi à D5 à
mon avis pour essayer de tout de suite
contrer le
centre mais tout de suite une petite
pression au temps côté
alirea c'est positif début de match très
positif pour le joueur
français pour moi son plan c'est Foug 5
dame D2 temporiser avec le cavalier et
voir et voir ce qu'il fait il fait fou6
pour moi il va jouer G5
ici pour moi il va jouer fou G5 mettre
la pression sur le cavalier donc sur la
case D5 aussi au passage je peux me
tromper après hein mais
euh pour moi c'est son
idée donc fou
C2
D5 voir cavalier
G3
[Musique]
C2 non c'est peut-être bien mais ça
laisse des5 quand
même
va faire dame 2 je
suppose il va jouer dame de je suis pas
pause il prend des 5 ouais je sais pas
c'est ça me fait toujours peur ce truc
mais je suis pas un joueur d'italienne
je sais que c'est un truc quand tu joues
pas l'italienne tu as toujours
l'impression que cette structure D3 et
C3 c'est pas terrible
terrible et je sais que les joueurs
d'italiennes ont beaucoup moins peur ils
réussissent toujours à faire du D4 et à
se libérer d'un seul coup
c'est plutôt mes Biet cognitifs sur
cavalier prend
D5 ah je pensais qu'il allait jouer le
truc complètement différemment là il a
enfin je sais pas il a joué un puis le
H3 va pas très bien sans le fait de
jouer
D4 de ce que je peux
savoir je crois c'est souvent bien pour
pour éviter fou G4 et taper sur la case
des4 il a pris du
fou mais bon ça évite de se prendre des
cavaliers G4 je sais pas il essae de de
brouiller les EOS là c'est intéressant
ce qu'il fait mais mais il va faire
petit
rock mais ouais il va mettre la tour en
E1 il va les contre-attaquer sur le pion
il va mettre le fou en G5 et peut-être à
un moment donné il va réussir à pousser
D4 et il va y avoir toutes les toutes
les pièces qui vont qui vont gicler sur
le roi adverse ah je suis toujours
étonné de de ces structures
italiennes ta première vue tu as
l'impression que ça va pas trop et puis
tout d'un coup ça tu as toutes les
pièces qui bam comme un élastique quoi
qui vient sauter à la tronche de
l'adversaire c'esti que là ça peut aller
tellement vite genre fou G5 qui menace
déjà cavalier H5 quand même et si fou A7
réussit pas vraiment à mettre la
pression sur la diagonal les pièces n
elles peuvent être un peu loin de leur
roi genre fou G5 dame D2 tour1 cavalier
H5 tout ça c'est des coups qui arrivent
vite il y a cavalier F5 aussi mais comme
je vous disais je suis toujours moi-même
étonné en fait là j'ai l'impression que
les blancs sont mieux alors qu'il y a
deux coup j'avais l'impression que
c'était les noirs qui étaient mieux
et je suis pas
biaisé par par la barre d'évaluation qui
est aux alentours des GAL de toute façon
l'ordinateur il est profondeur 22 donc
je vais vous dire ça va pas trop nous
aider mais tout d'un coup je vois
beaucoup de danger pour les Noirs alors
qu'il à peine de coups j'étais là en
mode wou les les les Noirs vont être
mieux mais ça c'est comme je vous dis he
cette structure je sais que j'ai
toujours cette cette fausse impression à
première vue voà j'ai l'impression que
dans dans dans 6 se coup c'est avantage
décisif blanc l'ordi dit quoi il fait
quoi je me le suis caché il fait dame D6
ah d D6 c'est pas bête par
contre et tour tour à D8 et sur fou G5
je suppose qu'il joue qu' joue h6 il a
joué4 ah il veut tout liquider ouais
c'est pas bête
aussi mais quoi que pion prend cavalier
prend fou F4 quand même que pr G3 pr G3
j'ai l'impression qu'on est sur les
meilleures
diagonales fou F4 pr G3 pr G3
en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on éteint
un peu le j'ai l'impression que le fou
G3 est supérieur au fou A7 genre un
genre de symétrie un peu bizarre entre
eux sauf qu'il y en a un qui est mieux
placé que l'autre G3 F pr G3 mets le fou
en B6 un jour tu vas peut-être te
faire te prendre une une marée de pion
ce qui est pas vrai pour le fou G3 tuas
un genre de de symétrie positive et tu
as le fou C2 qui me paraît mieux placé
que le fou des
5 vous voyezouj au alentours des GAL
pour l'ordi mais ouais prise G3 c'est
logique vous prend
G3 mais pour moi là c'est quand même
mieux pour les blancs genre vraiment
mieux fou B6 ok il continue à jouer
proche de la première
ligne sur dame D3 il veut quoi ah il
veut fou E4 ça c'est pas de B pour
nous et onarrive pas vraiment à faire
mon plan un
peu bizarre de de pousser les on a du
mal on est un peu bloqué pour le
moment Ali qui doit trouver une solution
auchmilblque dame D2 il y a foupr
F3 cavalier H2 c'est je je tombe dans la
bizarrerie C pour revenir vers G4 mais
je pense que c'est juste de la
bizarrerie H4 pour cavalier G5 il va
juste faire H6 je
suppose pas facile en fait les dam des3
fou4 cavalier me paraît pas si bête ça
me paraît débile et malin à la fois ce
qui généralement est mauvais
signe pas le signe d'un bon coup quand
même et est-ce qu'on peut jouer genre
tour1 prise1 et cavalier
prend pour laisser passer la dame après
retrouver du cavalier D3 peut-être
cavalier
F4 en partie personnellement je partirai
pour tour 1 prise 1 et cavalier prend et
l'ORD dit il part pour tour E1 tour
prend E1 pour dame prend E1 et laisser
fou prend F3 pu on prend F3
ah c'est intéressant j'aurais pas osé je
n'aurais pas osé j'aurais j'aurais fait
cavalier machin pour cavalier
prend al F H4 j'aime pas trop je pense
la dame vient juste en D6 on peut même
plus revenir en G3 il y aura du dame pr
G3
après il fait tour s'il fait pour dame1
c'est très très costaud de la part d'Ala
c'est costaud c'est très costaud parce
que c'est pas simple ah c'est vraiment
pas simple très très franchement ce
n'est pas
simple il comprend faut prend F3 GF
avantage c'est vraiment pas facile mais
oui la paire de fou est très puissante
dans cette position et la position est
très
ouverte j'ai déjà eu gagner des Blitz en
jou la même idée mais il fallait
vraiment comprendre c'était pas
facile c'était la meilleure manière pour
jouer
avantage et il a 2 minutes d'avance à la
pendule allez c'est bien ce qu' fait
c'est propre dame
F6 bon bah si on continue la même idée
on va jouer 2 on part du principe F
prend F3 d prend F3 prend F3 pu on prend
F3 c'est quand même avantage aussi à
pion C7 qui est un peu
fragile donc là c'est juste dame 2
normalement et puis on va enchaîner par
tour
D1 je suppose alors est-ce qu'il regarde
cavalier E5 mais il y a tour8 et on n
pas F4 on est
cloué les dames 2 tour D1 ça
paraît normal comme manière de continuer
on peut aussi mettre la tour en E1
après
comme souvent il essaie de trouver un
coup maximaliste alza peut-être qu'il
regarde un tour directour indirement
mais F pr pr pr le problème c'est que ça
menace pr G3 au
passage donc il y a pas de il y a pas de
fou4 ou de coup comme ça qui pourrait
potentiellement fonctionner après ça
fonctionner pas quand même mais et pu
aura pas de tour
des3 pour H2
ouais mais bon finast TR ça ça doit pas
passer ces trucs
là j'ai l'impression qu' qu' réfléchit à
donner le pion F3 genre même tour D1
prise F3 D3 tour D3
je raconte peut-être n'importe quoi en
fait
hein il y a un vrai monde où je raconte
nimp mais je comprends pas pourquoi dame
2 est pas
automatique c'est jouer je comprends pas
pourquoi c'était pas automatique en fait
ça me paraît tellement
logique al peut-être il y a cavalier H2
comme idée le
retour là par contre il y a une question
moi j'aurais pris de la
dame mais tu peux aussi dire que tu
prend du pion et que son roi va être
plus faible parce que tu vas pouvoir
mettre des batteries ouais c'est
peut-être très bien joué
ça j'aurais pas osé mais c'est peut-être
très bien
joué bon courage à lazavi quand même
parce que le roi va venir en G2 le
cavalier a vraiment du mal à intervenir
parce que cavalier 7 tour1 ah peut-être
il peut cavalier G6 c'est interdit d'am8
parce qu'il y a cavalier F8 à la fin bon
il fait G6 mais le cavalier a du mal à
revenir là je pense tour 1 va être joué
pour interdire cavalier
E7 pas laisser le cavalier revenir parce
que le cavalier il a envie he d'aller
sur cette case F5 là on lui coupe les
les
routes et next roi G2 je pense pour
stabiliser s'enlever du
clouage protéger un petit peu tout le
roi va être très bien placé là ça va
être 3g2 quasiment instantané parce que
vous voyez dame G5 ça peut être une
menace ça attaque le fou et ça menace
tour des de donc la roi G2 on stabilise
et alors là bonne chance pour la zavicin
là je souhaite bonne chance qu'est-ce
qu'il a bien joué àirea c'est il est
hyper fort c'est incroyable j'ai
l'impression qu'il se remet petit à
petit à rejouer comme quand il jouait
vraiment bien là il va faire H4 parce
que ça menace 5 et sur H4 H5 ça va lui
donner des idées de F fou F4 fou G5 donc
je pense qu'il va mettre le pion
H4 ah alordi propose encore plus malin
alordi proposit dame4 pour menacer F H4
F 4 j'aime bien il veut potentiellement
prendre et venir en5 avec le fou et
regardez la pression au temps il garde
sa minute
d'avance et là c'est dur he pour lazavic
alors j'aime beaucoup le coup de l'ordi
en une nouvelle fois pour défendre il
fait fou C5 pour mettre le fou D6 mais
fou C5 il faut vraiment regarder fou
prend C7 hein par qu' après c'est un
pion euh c'est un vrai pion de plus
parce que il est dans la
majorité fou C5 faut vraiment regarder
fou C7 j'aurais jamais osé fou
C5 en fait j'aurais arrêté le calcul
après fou prend C7 pour vous dire la
vérité j'aurais pas voulu donner le pion
après est-ce qu'il peut le
trouver peut-être mais euh sinon le
deuxième coup c'est A5 alors ça me
demandait pas pourquoi et après H5 c'est
le troisème coup mais c'est déjà
avantage blanc net d'après
lui parce que fou prend C6 dame prend C6
B4 ah en fait l'ORD dit considère que si
le fou ne revient pas sur les cases
noires proches du roi les blancs vont
jouer B4
ouais en fait là Lord dit il considère
que tu vas te prendre il fait fou prend
prise d'ame 8 et il considère que comme
le fou de case noire ne revient plus le
le roi noir est trop faible hyper
intéressant une nouvelle fois hyper
instructif mais on comprend pourquoi
e parce que si le Fou est bloqué sur
cette diagonale en fait il tape à Vita
mternam sur le pion F2 qui est
complètement défendu et les blancs eux
vont pouvoir taper sur le roi qui va
être esselé à 3 contre de
is bon l'ordi est trop fort une nouvelle
fois mais dur à comprendre quand
même relativement dur à comprendre que
fou prend C6 dame prend C6 et B4 enferme
le fou c'est assez costaud c'est assez
costaud et ce sera pas term la partie
mais ça ça si un avantage très costaud
il faut
avoir le niveau stratégique et tactique
ça pour le pour le
comprendre il faut avoir le niveau
stratégique pour le comprendre il fait
dame 8 en premier donc ça c'est la
recommandation de
base et sur tout reset il veut faire
comment
il va peut-être prendre prendre et
mettre le fou en
B3
astucieux le fou qui va venir taper de
concert avec la dame sur F7 et il y a
pas de cavalier F5 ah mais il aura
peut-être F C5 à ce moment là je pense
les noirs doivent jouer tour 7 tour
cavaler 7 a changé d'Avie et fou B3 fou
C5 et essayer de revenir en
D6 ça ça doit être la manière la plus
propre de tenter la
défense après est-ce que sur tour 7 on
peut jouer fou prend C6 t prend8 t
prend8 non je pense pas c'est
tropame pr C6
ok ouais 54 secondes contre 2 54 denav
en sueur il en difficulté là
laavic grosse difficulté là pour Denise
lazavic 2 minutes de retard position
difficile il fait tour D8 la dame qui va
venir en E4
maintenant là c'est Dame 4 là c'est Dame
monsieur attention il va avoir tour des
deux
derrière doit-il revenir vers eu
de doit dire revenir vers e de et ouais
il faudrait trouver le fou prend C6 et
B4 mais c'est vraiment difficile je me
répète mais c'est vraiment très
difficile
donc il fait dame 4 tour D7 et là
faudrait trouver fou prend C6 dame prend
C6 dame 8 et après le schmilblic avec
B4 difficile
oui très difficile très très
difficile ça va pas être trouvé je pense
alors comment on peut presser
sinon
dame G4 ça vaut quoi il fait F H4 j'aime
F H4 parce que sil fait G5 on va revenir
et ça nous donne fou C2 donc il va pas
jouer G5 c'est trop
affaiblissant et sur dame F5 on peut
peut-être prendre et prendre et remettre
le fou en G5 pour contrôler la case D2
on aura un vrai avantage structurel la
finale va être à défendre là je pense on
prend une fois déjà ah on peut aussi
prendre et
prendre
c'est un pion quand
même c'est un vrai
pion c'est complètement un
pion prise prise prise c'est un vrai
pion il hésite c'est pour ça il hésite
entre le pion et la finale qui peut être
sympathique hein on aura une vraiment
une mauvaise structure pour les noirs
des deux côtés de l'chiquier avec un
potentiel d'attaque avec du Tour 8 tour
à8 ou chose comme ça qui pourrait passer
par
derrière moi je pense que ça part pour
fou C6 pion C6 d dame F5 pion F5 et fou
G5 on remet le fou en F4 on l'installe
là-bas et on essaie de passer la tour
derrière et d'aller taquiner les pions
en sachant que si joue avec A5 on aura
toujours B4 AB CB et A4 A5
ouais ça part pour ça et fou
G5 alors l'ordi
pas mais pour moi c'était la manière la
plus logique de continuer la partie F6
FO F4 et il a roi F7 bon ok il va
défendre comme
ça alors sur sur B4 il va faire C5 donc
je pense qu'il va jouer A4 pour prendre
un peu
d'espace il touche à rien pour le moment
sur C5 on va jouer C4 ah C4 il aura tour
des 4 tour D3 c'est roi E2 ça c'est pas
un
problème tour D8 je pense il va faire
tour G1
maintenant attend j'ai un tour8 3 D3 fou
prend
F2 d'accord euh et tour D1 prise prise
et fouprend F2 mais il y aura fouprend
C7 donc il peut
pas il peut pas en fait parce que s'il
échange F2 contre C7 on obtient un 3
compte
qui crée une majorité et il aura un 3
contre 2 qui est stérile
ouais non ça c'est ça c'est merci
lazavic c'est RO2 roi D3 là déjà et
maintenant vous voyez regardez comparez
les structures et c'est pour ça qu'on
était content qu'il ait pas de pion
isolé de notre côté bon là c'est C4
échec là c'est C4 à 3 B4 à mon avis déjà
pour commencer B4 C4 d'ailleurs encore
mieux pourquoi s'embêter la même chose
mais en plus fort là c'est C4 merci de
dégager et à4 hein pourquoi s'embêter
quand on peut aller créer un pion passé
allez aquatro qui va partir bon ça c'est
sûr que c'est à 4 à mon
avis roi C3 pourquoi pas ah il veut se
donner roi B3 roi 4 mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont forts oh là là là là là là
ils sont extrêmement forts mais c'est
fou d'être aussi fort aux échecs en fait
comment
font-ils
je pense qu'il va jouer fou3 maintenant
pour mettre le fou en D4 ESS quand même
de gagner le pion F6 c'est
joué et là fou D4 fou5 et roi B3 ro D3
je pense qu'il va
revenir il commence par A4 ça change pas
grand-chose il met le pion en B5 c'est
bien donc là je pense qu' pion prend
A6 là il échange tout et il va rentrer
avec le
roi
alors comment est-ce qu'on termine F C5
échec B6 alors il veut B7 et fou a 7
maintenant les noirs qui sont aux abois
c'est le récital et là c'est roi D5 et
fou des4 et on va passer de l'autre côté
le récital mesdames et messieurs là
c'est fou des4 il va forcer fou
G5 alors cherche le gain forcé fou G5
est forcé et là s le fou arrivait sur la
bonne diagonale ce serait gagnant mais
il peut revenir va faire H4 peut-être
intermédiaire il fait B7 ah il peut
faire fou D6 fou prend D6 B8 ro prend B8
et roi prend D6 merci au revoir
lazavic là c'est rizinic
frérot Denise
rizainic merci au revoir le récital d'
fouja qui gagne la première partie avec
une technique immaculée
il doit pas être bien la zavic il a fait
très très très mal alira dans dans cette
partie et ça fait 1-0 allez plus qu'une
nulle et ala va va aller tout droit en
finale contre Magnus
Carlsen mais quelle partie quel
récital quel récital les
amis quelle finale quel jeu stratégique
quel milieu de
partie
ah ouais vraiment vraiment très très
belle partie très très belle
victoire bon ben allez plus qu'une nulle
et on a un français en
finale qui revient du Diable vaau
Vert et qui va aller prendre peut-être
20 cas déjà pour commencer
un petit 20k qui peut qui peut mettre
Gucci Gucci
Guca non c'est très très bien mesdames
et messieurs ça fait
plaisir français qui revient du du
tableau des perdants
alle re solide en
finale partie complètement
immaculée alors attendez vu que c'est EV
il faut que j'aille déjà sur la deuxème
partie parce que ça va commencer tout
seul et allez il manque plus qu'une nul
qui va à mon avis
obtenir notre petit
prince ah ça fait tellement
plaise
qui boit quelques gorgé d'eau
mais ça devrait pas
suffire et final c'est bo4 alors la
première finale sera en bo4 puis si al
gagne ce sera un bo2 donc il faudra
battre coup sur
coup notre
ami Magnus Carlsen dit le
saumon dit le
saumon allez c'est parti D4 cavalier
F6 et ça réfléchit déjà alors ça va
envoyer une Nzo ou un gambidame D5 ou
fou B4 alerza qui hésite
a qui a perdu un match contre le le
cours du jeu contre fedo CF au tout
début mais vraiment contre le cours du
jeu pour le coup et là
depuis il remonte il peut prendre des
gros points en vue des des
finales l'année prochaine je sais pas si
elles sont à Toronto ou pas d'ailleurs
je sais pas si on a un admin chesscom
pour nous pour nous dire si aller en
finale de ce tournoi nous qualifie
directement pour la prochaine étape en
mai c'est une information que je n'ai
pas et je vois qu'il y a du robinide
peut-être dans le chat et il a peut-être
cette information je sais pas si c'est
finaliste c'est pas le finaliste les
deux finalistes du Winner Bracket qui
sont automatiquement
qualifiés cavalier2 l'idée des blancs là
c'est de venir sur protéger le cavalier
C3 tout ça est théorique cavalier prend
des 5 ça joue le pion isolé c'est pas
idiot dans un must
twin
cavalier C6 fou C2 le fou a terminé son
travail peut-être qu'il va revenir vers
D6 B6 aussi un coup
évidemment mais il regarde dame D3 parce
que d D3 cavalier F6 aura fou
G5
h j'aime bien le trisème coup de l'ordi
damage 4 que je trouve intéressant qui
vient anticiper les menaces sur sur H7
mais en fait je pense c'est la même idée
de fou D6 c'est comme ça sur dame D3 il
veut jouer dame
H4 pour protéger H7 et attaquer
H2
il joue fou E7 donc il veut dame D3 G6
et remettre le fou en F6 G7 aussi très
logique à vrai dire en fait il y avait
beaucoup d'options et de setup c'est
difficile parfois de choisir une autre
option çaurait été de jouer tour8 pour
dame D3 G6 et gagner un tempo en
remontant le fou directement à
F8 on dit dans le chat c'est étonnant de
voir alierard revenir un si haut niveau
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
euh dans le sens où on a on l' vu
peut-être il a il a un peu quitté les
échecs pendant quelques mois après les
candidats il avait probablement
euh besoin de de
récupérer mais là il est revenu euh il
est revenu très fort donc A3 c'est pour
éviter les cavaliers B4
je suppose qu'il va jouer fou F6
ici je suppose qu'il va mettre le fond
en
F6 le coup simple et
efficace mais
peut-être qu'il faut pas prendre trop de
temps afin de le jouer c'est peut-être
bête de de temporiser comme
ça enin c'est peut-être bête c'est pas
le mot que je veux dire c'est peut-être
dommage donc il joue
B6 il veut mettre le F en
B7 sur fou H6 a tour
E8 et tour AD1 fou F6 et fou
B7 je pense que les blancs vont tenter
cavalier E4 pour essayer de déranger un
peu le la mise en place des Noirs mais
bon fou
B7 c'est un fion isolé qui se passe bien
je suis désolé enin je suis
désolé je suis désolé pour pour Monsieur
lazavic
hein
je suis très content en
fait l'air facile là quand même il s'est
bien mis en
place à no que même des coups comme fou
G5 parfois sont
possibles cavalier7 cavalier F5 après
cavalier7 cavalier F6 cavalier F5 B7
tout cette mise en
place qui est pas
mauvaise pour moi là il fait mal alza il
fait très très
mal il fait excessivement mal
ici il est en train de mettre son
adversaire aux
abois obligé de gagner la zavic
pour rester dans ce
match
va je jouer fou
F6
simple
basique simple et
basique
efficace fou B7 être aussi simple et
basique et
efficace normalement il veut pas enfin
l'ORD dit il veut qu' prend des 5 puis
on prend des 5 mais évidemment il veut
pas ça c'est trop
symétrique donc là il veut quoi il veut
cavalier prend C3 pion prend C3
ouais bon ouais pourquoi
pas
ok il y a un truc fort mais compliqué
c'est fou F6 peut-être je suis pas sûr
cavalier A5 j'aime bien cavalier A5
humain dans pas mal de variantes ça
protège le fou
B7 toujours pareil he si on est si on
liquide tout en D5 sera peut-être pas
moins bien avec les Blancs quoi que même
là on sera peut-être moins bien mais on
sera jamais
mieux et il veut cavalier C4
next aussi
ou cavalier prend
C3 et sur prend B7 prend2 et prend B7
il peut vouloir plein de trucs
là il peut vraiment vouloir cavalier
prend C3 et F prend le
4 bien comme il
faut je pense qu'il va jouer un coup
comme tour AD1 mais bon c'est un peu
triste il a peut-être qu' C4 aussi ouais
je sais pas il y a vraiment beaucoup
d'options elles ont toutes l'air
intéressantes pour les
Noirs alors pas forcément dans l'optique
de prendre l'avantage mais dans
l'optique de vraiment complètement
égaliser et finalement remporter le
match
match c'est force qui fait alira
aujourd'hui la flamme s'est éteinte chez
chez lazavic lui qui était tellement
fort dans les premiers matchs
ouais comme un grain de de
sable mais les blancs là le cavalier de
en fait est mal placé pour jouer la
structure et là il commence à tellement
tanker ah là il commence vraiment à tank
est fort en
plus fait tour
C1 il y a du cavalier B3 mais B3 qui
D5
quandme
prendre je sais pas al on le vaacin de
chacune des quatre étape se qualifie
pour la phase finale de les deux
finalistes de la grande finale d'entalif
pour la division 1 de l'ENT suivant évid
que le Play et le vainqueur de la
division 2 aussi ouais voilà c'est
ça que si al gagne cette partie il sera
qualifié automatiquement à la division 1
du du prochain
tournoi en gros il se met déjà très bien
pour se qualifier au prochain champion
chestour en
gagnant mais oui c'est à peu près l'info
que
j'avais al don fou 5 si comme coup
principal fou5 c'est du classique hein
de cette structure prise et dame
prend et la grande finale sera mercredi
hein mercredi chzcam fr va nous le
confirmer ça a laissé alira le temps de
bien jouer le title Tuesday
demain
qui essaie quand même de trouver comment
mettre la pression
grand et mercredi demain mardi c'estion
2 on sera pas là pour la suivre je vous
préviens fr mais
bon on va manquer quand même quelque
chose
d'assez
exceptionnel
fa pas oublier de bien aller
voir il fait foug5
thématique fou G5 F prend G5 dame prend
G5
ouais c'est tellement thématique et
maintenant si tu prends tout le temps
des 5 ben enfin tu peux avec les Blancs
tu vas pas être moins bien mais tu vas
pas être
mieux juste nul
quoi c'est juste
nul je sais pas si peux faire mieux que
ça en
fait
que prochain coup c'est tour des tu vas
même te retrouver moins bien après il
est probablement
obligé
IL3 C de d'ailleurs maintenant à
signaler quand
même vcent est-ce que on a qui on va
avoirer contre
B pere adversaire très
difficile
B3 il pourrait y avoir qui prend des 5
intermédiaires alle sur cavalier D2 f6ou
B3 D55 de toute façon bah je vois pas
comment encore une fois les noirs ne
sont pas mieux c'est juste que je ne
vois pas comment dans dans le dans
l'optique du match comment les Blancs
jouent le gain en fait juste comment les
blancs
essayent
en tout cas
Alera reprend le le devant a
temp
alle Reza qui joue exceptionnellement
bien aujourd'hui lazavic un petit peu en
deedans complètement ded la zavic dans
ce match étouffé par
Al donc ça dire que pour le prochain
tourno en on aura minim alors ce sera
juste après les candidats je sais pas à
quel point il aura encore l'énergie pour
jouer par contre mais il sera toujours
là pour prendre un peu
DEAS ça fait toujours plaisir un tout
petit peu de Kade qui tombera qui sera
vraiment pas très bien placé dans le
dans le calendrier et donc il prend
plutôt du pion alors sur il y avait
peut-être un problème
qui était cavalier C3 avec l'idée fou
prend cavalier prend et tu as touché la
case F6 donc c'est pour ça qu'il joue pu
on prend et fout des TR tour 7 et tour
terrible
après à moins que vous vouz absolument
suivre les finales de la deuxème
division mais je pense que si Maxime
joue le title Tuesday vous allez être
plus chaud poursivre le
title envie d'envoyer de la kayas ça sur
une question là il menace de faire mat
mais oui juste res il y a un problème en
fait avec le cavalier à la fin prend5
prend
des5 prend5 il réussi à avoir un pion de
plus mais il va pas le
observer il a quand même joué le truc le
plus agressif tour 8 il encore cavalier
C3 je me suis peut-être un petit peu
avancé en besogne mais il y aura tour D8
après et T reprend des
qu a BTU BO hier c'est un match
complètement fou maintenant B pour la
finale du loser bracket dans la D de
contre Aronian ah bah il va gagner Boin
fait sur des H8 direct et ça c'est
avantage blanc à cause de dame B5
j'avais pas vu la variante j'avais
complètement raté cette idée làav qui a
mis longtemps avant de la trouver
is dame B5 ah ouais c'est
pas on a é un peu biaisé euh et par euh
ma faiblesse de calcul et par la la
barre
par la barre la barre qui nous avait
donné la
barre semble tellement proche d'être
complètement
égal tellement proche mais ouais tour D1
et on narrive pas à récupérer le pion
pas tout de suite en tout
cas je suis un peu étonné
mais
les blanc vraiment trouvé la meilleure
chance pratique et ont poussé ala à
l'erreur il a donné une une variante
difficile à trouver ala il a encore des
petites
chances de tenir le demi-point laav de
tenir la victoire
laavic ou par que tour des5 dame D3
attention
finalement il a pas été
prudent gagn hein pour la zavic ça là
malheureusement pour
nous le cavaliion a 5 qui a pas eu le
temps d'intervenir il va jouer peut-être
dame C2 cavalier C3 oh non j'ai j'ai
peur que ça perde là qu'on aille sur
l'Armageddon ah ce serait tellement
dommage lui qui dominait euh tellement
euh il est parti
joue tour C8
ouais c'est bien joué tour C8 il veut
dame C2 cavalier C3 t prend C3 sur
cavalier G3 je crois qu' qui va quand
même partir en C2 essayer de mettre le
cavalier en B3 de récupérer B2 ou
quelque chose comme ça là il va faire
dame
C2 ça va transposer
finalement la tour non il va peut-être
jouer ah dame F1 il peut pas il y a dame
prend B2 tour B1 c'est bizarre il fait
tour1 oh tour 1 c'est bien joué dame D2
il va jouer
D5 attention Alireza mais D5 peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut revenir avec cavalier
C4 cavalier D6 pour fermer toutes les
portes fermer les
écoutilles faut pas laisser pénétrer là
la zavic allez un petit tour de mais
très très bien tour de dame c ça
mettrait
Gucci ça mettrait GUC
même donc il joue tour 8 bon ah on est
pas obligé de prendre pourquoi on ferit
pas dame5
attention donc on échange il va revenir5
avec la dame on revient en
G8 fais pas de dinguerie alirea fais pas
de
dinguerie il pense à ro h6 il pense à ro
h6 il r fou ah mais parce qu'il a peur
de roi G8 et cavalier4 qui arrive
ça va pas tenir ça en fait leur dit don
égal mais ro G8 H4 ça fait hyper
peur il faud jouer cavalier C4 oh là là
là là là H4 cavalier C4 seul
coup faut chasser cette dame là de la
diagonale le don aussi dame prend B2
cavalier D5 cavalier C4 mais ça fait
extrêmement peur cavalier C4 jouer
direct un petit coup de bol là pour
Alireza quand même qui a encore cette
défense dame F6
ça fait peur ça fait
peur ça fait extrêmement peur
c'est pas que ça fait peur mais c'est
que ça fait giga peur parce que cavalier
D5 cavalier E7 on va être tellement
proche de se faire mater
je la sens je le sens pas la défendre
celle-là est-ce qu'on peut jouer dame
prend B2 cavalier D5 et dame prend
A3
oh
euh c'est ce que j'aurais joué mais ça
perd comment je ve juste regarder
comment ça perd par curiosité cavalier 7
3 F8 k C8 3 G8
H5 genre ça l'ordi donne complètement
perdant ah parce que tu as pas d'AM F8 à
cause de cavalier au 7 retour et tu mat
ou là il a joué dame prend B2 cavalier
D5 alors là le seul coup c'est cavalier
D2 euh
ouais bon il fait dame B1 ouais mais ça
va être ouais il y a dame4 il y avait
pas dame F5 à cause de cavalier E7 bon
c'est bien joué quand même parce qu'il
touche un peu les
pions et là cavalier E7 cavalier C6
c'est le c'est la solution pour les
blanc cavalier 73 F8 cavalier C6 menace
d'AM H8 mat force plus ou moins le
retour en
G8 ce qu'il va
avoir et après 5 ouais il va avoir tous
les coups en fait ah c'est terrible ro
G8 est forcé D5 va arriver alors ilacera
pas D6 tout de
suite ça paraît indéfendable pour
Alireza mais qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué
la zavic une nouvelle fois un
récital cavalier prend
à7 peut-être dame 6 c'est le coup
humain dame si c'est fichtrement humain
comme
coup il prend à 3 il revient en C4
ok bah il se trouve que c'est là il y a
pas d'ame 5 ah non il y a B6 qui tombe à
la fin alors B5 faut pousser pousse il
pousse et maintenant sur D6 on a dame 5
dame 5 dame 5 dame 5 il laisse let's go
et il y a plus qu' prend B6 à la fin k
B6 B4 D7 cavalier
C6 pourquoi il est pas venu en C6 avec
le cavalier il me fait peur mais bon ça
doit aller D7 qui prend des7 qui prend
des7
B3 mais il revient non il est dans le
carré il est complètement dans le carré
alors ça ça peut être quand même nul
faut faire roi F6 roi F3 H5 hyper
important ah c'est facile ça H5 hyper
important s'il fait pas H5 c'est perdu
mais c'est hyper facile ouais c'est joué
pour pas laisser G4 et là roi E6 et si
le roi s'approche du pion on va de
l'autre côté et normalement il peut plus
bouger il fait F5 c'est quand même malin
B prends-le hein pourquoi il le prend
pas B prends-le il te le donne ah il
veut nous mettre en zugzang
l'enfoiré
alors attendez l'enfoiré veut nous
mettre en
zugzang parce qu'en fait il a des coups
d'attente c'est un peu le problème il va
faire ro G5 ro E5 roi prend est-ce qu'on
peut faire F4 là est-ce qu'on avait pas
F4 ah mais on a ro C2 cavalier A3 et ro
B3 qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué de la
part d'Ala force la nul et c'est Cho
monsieur lazavic vas-y joue le G frérot
vas-y
amuse-toi
commence par par jouer poliment
frérot alord d don F6 échec comme
gagnant c'est
trop c'est pas encore complètement
terminé ah mais il y a pas d'échec il a
pas
d'échec
ah il bloque
c'est bien joué dame
6 c'est pas fait
encore il va faire dame D2 non il fait
dame
C7 mais vas-y juste B2 sur dame prend F7
il a dame D6 dame G3 bonne chance pour
gagner le pion
frère bonne chance vas-y ramène le roi
Ali vas-y ramène le
roi vas-y dame 6 vas-y bonne chance
vas-y bonne chance vas-y gagne le pion
vas-y amuse-toi là vas-y vas-y vas-y
dégage pour voir et merci dégage pour
voir et ben voilà et ben voilà c'est une
finale mesdames et messieurs ça c'est
ciao bah ala qui va juste éteindre son
PC derrière c'est merci au revoir il
passe la première là il il se barre
merci j'enlève la caméra de derrière et
c'est
ciao c'est
ciao il y a pas une deuxième vie non la
zavic là il a plus de vie là là il a
plus de vie mesdames et messieurs la vie
est terminée côté
lazavic et c'est Aliza qui se qualifie
pour la grande finale il a pas eu le
droit du bon côté il avait le gain non
il y avait pas de gain là là ça là il y
avait plus de gain là c'était terminé là
c'était terminado
ah ça me Gucci là là ça me Gucci
lera qui vient sortir nepo et lazavi
coup sur coup très très très très très
bien joué de la part du joueur français
qui se qualifie donc pour la grande
finale contre nul autre que le champion
du monde de rapide et de Blitz Magnus
Carlsen
ah ça va il s'en est bien
sorti c'est ciao c'est ciao mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
ce ce live c'était bien sympa victoire
d'aliire Reza on se retrouvera nous donc
demain normalement pour le title Tuesday
qu'on suivra ensemble peut-être même
avec du Maé le soir et mercredi pour
cette grand finale entre alirea firouja
et Magnus Carlsen finale de rêve
entre deux des tout enfin le meilleur
joueur du monde et un des tout meilleurs
joueurs du monde et Alireza en plus qui
se qualifie pour le tournoi en mai merci
à tous d'avoir suivi ce live et je vous
dis à très bientôt ciao
ciao vous voulez streamer des échecs
comme vos créateurs préférés tels que
bstream Naka ou les sœurs BZ let's go
on le programme de Community streamer
deess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte àess.com et profitez de la
visibilité offerte par d're plateformes
de jeu il vous suffit de relier votre
compte à
chess.com/settings/connecting-ons mettre
échec comme catégorie sur twitch et
commencer à streamer bénéferez d'une
expérience sans publicité sur Chess.com
et apparaîtrez dans notre liste de
streamers en direct votre profil
Chess.com affichera votre stream twitch
qui sera aussi mis en avant durant vos
parties off utiliseer la commande
community streamer dans le chat et
faites grossir votre audience sans plus
attendre
[Musique]